you got him real Haggar song on this
record hmm how old were you when you saw
Merle Haggard for the first time oh gosh
oh God you know the night I'll never
forget this the first night I got to see
him live was the first night I ever got
to sing with Emmylou Harris it was one
of the greatest nights of my life she
agreed to go find this club Merle was
playing that in 30 45 minutes away so we
piled in a couple limos and all went to
see Merle and I got to see Merle for the
first time in a beer joint it was the
greatest experience ever and he took me
on the bus to meet Marilyn she said this
is one you need to know about more all
his kids got the goods and he's the real
deal and said his name's Vince Gill and
tomorrow I know who he is he's that boy
that wrote this song Leona's got out
right now so he knew who I was yeah it
was awesome and then we played a few
shows together a bunch of years later
and then the last few years of his life
we got to be really close he I think he
got to know how much I really revered
him mm-hmm and then I got to record I
got to do some harmony vocals on some of
the very last recordings he ever made
and in the morning he died I just sat
down and wrote that song you know you
needed to do that yeah that's how I
grieve is it yeah that's what I that's
where I go I go to music for for grief
it's cheaper than therapy
[Laughter]